great warriors that you lost in Malley
13 helicopters was they said I've got a
new report on it we talked about it and
please give my condolences to the
families and different great fighters
you've done a fantastic job in that
whole area it's a tough area so we
appreciate it very much
we'll be talking about a lot of things
including they don't want including
trade we do a lot of trade with France
and we have a minor dispute I think
we'll probably be able to work it out
but we have a big trade relationship and
I'm sure that within a short period of
time things will be looking very rosy we
hope that's usually the case with the
two of us we get it worked out we've had
a lot of good lot of good things we've
done a lot of good things together as
partners our countries have been
partners in many good ventures including
some having to do with radical Islam and
others and it's always worked out so I
look forward to our discussion we made a
lot of progress in our first 25 minutes
and we intend to make a lot of progress
in our next hour
maybe our than half so thank you very
much Matthew beaucoup me sick buddy
don't speak Mexican dirty words upset
City Davi you know because you're both
on that what it demands a super ability
to fight against but it's already
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what further my clone was saying about
NATO well we just began discussing NATO
and what I like it about NATO is that a
lot of countries have stepped up I think
really it might be hessed and also
yourself you're close to the put up a
lot of money I told you it was a hundred
thirty million dollars one hundred and
thirty billion dollars and that's a lot
and they're now stepping up again it's
going to be four hundred billion dollars
over a very short we have commitments
for four hundred billion dollars and we
just left the Secretary General and he
he's got some things that are very
important and I discussed within the
flexibility so that we have it not just
with one area of the world you and I
discussed this all the time we have all
areas of the world because they there's
a lot different than it was and now it's
certainly a lot different over the last
three years so we have a lot of
countries stepping up and putting up a
lot of money the number as of this
moment is exactly a hundred and
thirty-one billion dollars that's a year
that's a tremendous amount of money but
it's not enough and they also raised and
have commitments for four hundred
billion dollars so NATO which was really
heading in the wrong direction three
years ago it was heading down if you
looked at a graph it was to a point
where I don't think they could have gone
on much longer now it's actually very
strong and getting stronger
many people are
you
both agree on that so that we can use it
for other things not just looking at one
specific country no a lot of people say
it was meant to look at originally the
Soviet Union now Russia but we also have
other things to look at whether it's
radical Islamic terrorism whether it's
the tremendous growth of China there are
a lot of other things so NATO is
becoming different than it was much
bigger there was and much younger there
was because people are not fulfilling
their commitments there are some
countries that are fulfilling their
commitment to those countries are going
to be dealt with
maybe I'll deal with them from a trade
standpoint maybe I'll deal with them in
a different way what's something asked
where they have to pay but you know we
don't want to have people delinquent
we're not really good sphere for us to
be involved including friends by the way
to be involved in you have countries
that aren't paying their way they you
know less than one percent you have a
couple that are less than one percent
not fair
so NATO has made a lot of progress over
the last three years and the word
flexibility is very important they're
not just looking at one area now they're
looking at the world and that's very
important to me it's very important you
know I I know that's my statement
created some reactions take the leader
be a lot of people I do stand by and I
have to see when you look at what what
NATO even should be first of all this is
a burden we share and present from just
to mind you some figures and the fact
that this is typically that the u.s.
over-investment dictate that that we
came and number one by far and they do
share the statement that's why I'm this
point supportive of the stronger
European component in nature which is
exactly what you have done so in terms
of fostering we are investing 1.9
percent of our GDP we are increasing our
GDP who will be at the nominal but when
we speak about later it's not just about
money we have to be respectable results
obvious the first burden we share the
first off eBay is also business and I do
believe that in such circumstances we do
pay what we have to pay for quality
you
my point is that we have today study to
try positions to be to be done it's
impossible just to say you have to keep
money where to put soldiers without to
be clear from the fundamentals of what
NATO should be and peace after the
decision of the end of the INF treaty we
have to continue because now this is a
reason for Germany France and a lot of
European countries to have new meat
science coming from Russia
exposing us we need such a clarification
and I want a European component to be
part of the future negotiations of
section the new IANA when we speak about
the energy I would say of the Alliance
what is the objective to protect our
partners against external threats and
France will do it and all the states in
Europe but the common enemy to date a
man as we mentioned and I'm sorry to say
that you don't have the same definition
of terrorism on the table when I look at
Turkey they now are fighting against
those who fight with us before Twitter
shoulder-to-shoulder against Isis and
sometimes they work with Isis if you
just have description about what we pay
and we don't have we are not serious
we are not tell you for something we
understood for how people how long term
in Europe movies to the enemy today and
let's be clear and welcome together on
that I know that we do share exactly the
same
maybe less business exposure of the US
meets small European investment and
modern ideas Europe inside I do agree
being strict and very efficient against
re-tear ways books leaves happy
clear clear definition of these groups
and norm dignity I'd like to say that
you've been really doing a great job in
Africa and you've been very much
involved there more than most and that's
been fantastic I appreciate you saying
the United States for decades has been
paying really way way disproportionately
to much for NATO and you'd have other
countries paying far too little that are
very directly benefited by it and by the
United States involvement and we're
changing that around somewhat and it's
very important but we're a very
important player I think without us nato
certainly is not the same thing as we
discuss and discuss it at length
this morning we discussed it with
Secretary General Stoltenberg but we're
behind you 100% and all of the money
that's been raised at all of these
countries that are all of a sudden
putting up money it's a great thing to
see but we do have a great we really
have a different objective I think right
now we're looking at a much bigger
picture and that includes well it
includes you mentioned Iraq but it
really includes a ran - I think massive
riots having protests all over the
country and they're killing a lot of
people everybody knows that that's why
they turned off their internet system so
nobody can find out but if the media
would go there and it's I think very
hard for the media to go there frankly
right now but they're killing a lot of
people but data has come a long way in
three years and something that we're
very proud of because well with them and
they don't serve as a fantastic function
if everybody's involved if they're not
involved and I would believe that the
president is very much involved in like
she had
nobody wants it also to be utilized
properly but it's not utilized properly
we all agree right that's no good so
we've had a very good discussion a lot
of people and we're meeting with a lot
of countries later as you know and
they're really stepping up for the most
part they're all stepping up we have one
or two that aren't then we'll have to
deal with them in a different way maybe
we as I said we'll deal with them on
trade we have a lot of power with
respect to trade they make a fortune
with the United States and then they
don't pay their bills that's no good but
NATO has come a long way in three years
that it's become very powerful I think
very very powerful and it's become I
think a much fairer statement in terms
of the United States because we're able
to go down a little bit we were paying
for 24.3% of the largest GDP ever
nobody has ever had a GDP like we have
right now and nobody's to come close and
other people were paying 1% some people
were paying less than one percent of a
very small GDP it's not fair and if they
get attacked we protect them but it's
not fair so a lot of cages have been
made filled up
and what will your process be in
determining for what additional products
from France you might have like hair
like well we're working on that right
now we know we have discussed it I think
we'll be able to work something out I
hope and maybe not maybe we'll do it
through texting you know we can work it
out easily through taxing but the text
you know they're American companies the
tech companies if you're talking about
they're not my favorite people because
they're not exactly for me but that's
okay I don't care they're American
companies and we want to tax American
companies so that's important we want to
tax them that's not what somebody else
to tax and as the president knows we
text lines we have whether taxes
schedule but we'd rather not do that but
that's the way it would work so it's
either they were cattle will work out
some YouTube beneficial tax and the tax
will be substantial and I'm not sure
it's gonna come to that what am I
mister president has Frank's commitments
get off my husband taking back
firefighters well I haven't asked that
did the president today I have over the
period of time we have a tremendous
amount of captured fighters Isis
fighters over in Syria and they're all
under lock and key but many are from
France many are from Germany many of
them UK they're mostly from Europe and
some of the countries are agreeing I
have not spoken to the president about
that would you like some nice Isis
fighters I could give them cupidity
negative you can take everyone you want
let's be serious a very large number of
fighters you have on the ground
I'm conscious coming from Syria from
foreign fighters coming from Europe but
it's a tiny minority all of them we have
in the region and I think number one
priority because it's not yet finished
it could get rid of Isis and destroys
whoops this is our number one priority
and it's not yet done I'm sorry to say
that yes you see that fighters in this
region in Syria and now in Iraq and more
and more
and for the oldest civilization of the
region makes the situation more
difficult to fix the situation against
Isis secondly some of these foreign
fighters are being killed in Iraq
because of the deeds precisely they
acted in this very rigid and we would
have a case by construction we have a
humanitarian approach for children or
radio commands and we will have a case
like a toothbrush but for me is a very
first objective in the region is to
finish war against Isis and and and
don't don't make any mistake your
number-one problem our most foreign
fighters this is the Isis fighters in
duration and you have more and more
these fighters due to the situation
today this is why he's a great
politician because that was one of the
greatest non-answers i've ever and
that's okay because sometimes you can
have some temptation from these you see
the US side I don't say both present
front but could be the press to say this
is the European responsibility I'm sorry
to say that we have some of our people
but if you don't think at the reality of
the situation that is number one not to
be ambiguous with these groups this is
why we started to discuss about our
relations with Turkey but I think any
ambiguity with Turkey these are vicious
groups
he's detrimental to everybody for the
situation of the top friends has
actually taken back some fighters but we
have a lot of Fighters we captured a lot
of people and we have captured a hundred
percent of the Caliphate that you know
that that means that it's still early
going and going
we said a small contingent in and we
wiped out another portion of Isis we
don't want to happen to me what happened
with Prez
Obama wear it reformed and then it
became stronger than it was in the first
place and we don't want that to happen
and as I said before we've taken the oil
we have the oil so we have total control
of the oil so that then I couldn't be
able to use that they use that oil to
really to fuel up their wealth to fuel
up their their money that was their
primary source of income and they make
contributions so we have now lists of
where these contributions come from
which is very important you have people
contributing if you can believe it some
of these people are wealthy people that
make contributions and we have lists
where we learned a lot you know when we
got al baghdadi
that was a great gift and when we killed
him we have a lot of information that we
so the funny comedian is kinetic energy
listen to me ray
[Music]
we don't expect
you know I came into a position where
the European Union was making anywhere
from a hundred to a hundred and fifty
billion dollars a year in deficits to
the United States they will make it and
we were losing it and so we had to do
something that is fair that's a beer I
think fair we're losing tremendous
amounts of money as you know the
European Union is very strong in
barriers barriers meeting certain of our
products can't commit including
agricultural product it just can't come
in we can't sell it and yet the European
Union sells openly to the United States
and generally untaxed or taxed at a low
level so these are problems that we're
talking about these are problems that
we're working out and you know the
digital tax is the least I know I
inherited a situation where the European
Union which was foolin partially for
this reason I guess for a lot of reasons
it was formed but partially to make
better or take advantage of the United
States and they've done that for
brilliantly and frankly it's not right
so I've exposed it a lot of people
didn't know it and we're doing things
about it we have no choice because the
United States can't continue to lose the
kind of money that they've lost over the
last literally since the formation of
the European Union and I think we'll
work something out they want to talk as
you know the new head wants to talk it
was supposed to be very respected woman
very highly respected and I look forward
to meeting her they want to meet but we
have a very unfair trade situation where
the u.s. loses a lot of money for many
many years with the European Union
billions and billions of those I mean to
be specific the hunt over a hundred and
fifty billion dollars a year so we don't
want to be doing that and we we can make
a deal we can take a harsh approach we
can solve that problem instantaneously
we want to do it but I don't want to do
that these are friends of ours these are
people that we've had very extraordinary
relationships within I do personally and
I'm sure
can work something in does the United
States support these protesters in Iran
I don't want to comment on that but the
answer is no but I don't want to comment
on this one of the United States to do
more than standing up to Americans are
applying the terms of that relationship
are you supportive of those efforts by
our NATO allies are you standing in the
way well I can only say we have a very
good relationship with Turkey and the
president heard Awad I do I can speak
for the president of experience tonight
we have a very good relationship we
pulled our soldiers that we said you can
patrol your own border now I don't care
who you do it with well we're not gonna
have soldiers patrolling the border
that's been fought over for 2,000 years
but we took our soldiers app we put some
of those soldiers around the oil where
we've captured the oil and taken the oil
and we have the oil but we've and we've
brought some home and we will be
bringing some home and we've sent some
to other areas okay but we have a very
good relationship with Turkey and just
to be clear we have hello corporations
to study when security great migration
zones are insulated turns out with you
the European Union in France I do
respect all leaders whatever they can
say even bad things about myself I can
respect I never slept with anybody but
it's now it's a question for this may
personally I think we need color
education from the Turkish side this is
not a street qualifies them but and what
they are they
I do believe at least we have to Cardiff
occasions to be asked how is it possible
to be a member of the Alliance to work
with office to by our mothers to be
integrated and to by the s400
commissions
technically it is not possible since
constitutions to be provided by the
traffic spreading as far as you want to
be part ii i understand from
that they want to block all the
declarations of this summit if we do not
agree about their definition of
terrorist organizations qualifying YPG
and the others
that's the Oasis which is not our
definition these two points have to be
connected if they want to to be a
serious member of the Alliance
mr. president this is really why we're
having meetings those are points and
we'll be discussing that with the
president today yes mr. nobley you issue
sanctions on Turkey
over their purchase of the s400 missile
system we're looking at it now and we're
talking about it now as you know turkey
wanted to buy our Patriot system and the
Obama administration wouldn't let them
and they only let them when they were
ready to buy another system which is not
the same system but Turkey for a long
period of time wanted very much to buy
the Patriot system which is our system
which is what NATO uses which is a great
system which is the best system they
wouldn't sell it to Turkey so you know
there are two sides of the story I have
to say this but we will be discussing
that with Turkey Levin well we'll be
meeting with Turkey in a little while
and also tomorrow
so to be clear above the tip point and
two for you to have them it's a full all
of you they were discussing with
Europeans on Sam PE and we accepted to
sell the Sam PT to them
so this receiver is not you and one
other question explained by the refusal
a few years ago the Americans not to
sell the batteries itself their own
decision even having a European option
totally compliant with NATO so they
decided not to
sir mr. president Prime Minister Johnson
I believe it's organizing some sort of
discussion later today about the Syria
conflict are you going to take part in
that and meet with him and if not why
are you talking about he's really risen
rapidly what is he yes we'll be meeting
with Prime Minister Johnson in a while
I'll be seeing him later on we're going
over to number 10 which is a very
exciting place to be as you know and
we'll be discussing a lot of different
things yes no I don't have a comment on
the London Bridge attack other good to
say that I was very proud of those
people that grabbed him and it's a good
job between the fire extinguishers and
whatever else it was an amazing job they
did and he was very violent you could
see that I mean this was captured very
much on tape I think the the way the I
think they were British citizens the way
they said that was incredible that was
very great so a terrible thing terrible
attack a lot of people very badly hurt I
believe three or four killed is it for
nap today
so it's terrible it's a terrible thing
and I know it's an act of terrorism it's
been declared an act of terrorism
radical Islamic terrorism by the way and
it's very bad very bad but I think the
PT the way they stepped up to me that
was something very special okay
I don't think he does until then I think
we get along with Russia I think we can
get along with Russia I think you feel
we can get along with Russia we've
discussed that before but certainly we
have to be prepared whether it's Russia
or somebody else we have to be prepared
but he and I have a pretty similar view
on them I think we feel that we can get
along with Russia and I think it's a
good thing to get along with Russia and
I campaigned on it and then I go into
big stadiums people like it and the
Russian people would like to see if - a
lot of good can come of it but the
purpose of NATO is the flexibility over
the last two years which is the moment
procedure is if initial the -
communication between the core we have
whether these improper well Alex firms
different open for it
it is come on scientists from putting
[Music]
we
I think the situation in Ukraine is
important I think that the meetings
coming up with Russia and Ukraine are
very important and there's a possibility
that's a very big progress can be made
it's very important for Ukraine I think
it's very important from the standpoint
of Russia also that they work out a
treaty they work out peace because
they've been fighting a long time too
long and I think there's a really good
chance that that will happen also with
respect to nuclear weapons
I've spoken to President Putin and I
communicated with him and we are he very
much wants to and so do we work out a
treaty of some kind or nuclear weapons
that will probably then then include
China at some point and yourselves by
the way but it will include China and
some other countries but we intend to
see if we can work something out to stop
the proliferation to stop
what's happening because we are making a
lot and we are renovating a lot frankly
the whole situation with nuclear is not
a good it's not a good situation we
ended the treaty because it wasn't being
adhered to by the other side but they
want to make a treaty in so do we and I
think would be a great thing I think
it's one of the most important things we
can do frankly so whether it be dealing
with Russia upon a treaty where we
really and we're focused on nuclear and
nuclear weapons missiles but nuclear
weapons and we think something can be
worked out we think they want to do it
we know they want to do it and we want
to do it also
I spoke to China about it they do it in
one of our trade negotiations they were
extremely excited about getting involved
in that so some very good things could
happen with respect to that I think it's
very important the whole nuclear
situation very very important thank you
all very much
[Music]